so we're here today to talk about full
stack um machine learning uh and
generative AI for all of you and us data
scientists and and machine learning
Engineers um part of the intention here
is you know I've worked in education for
a long time um in the in the data
science machine learning and uh AI space
and there there still are certain
impedance mismatches between um what we
teach and what happens in practice in a
in a in a business and Enterprise
industrial setting for for data science
so we're going to try to move towards
what it looks like to do production uh
machine learning and generative AI today
um so essentially thinking about how we
build software systems um and ml systems
that incorporate our data and AI okay um
so to that end let's let's jump in um
and the first thing I want to talk about
is full stack machine learning um and
then we're going to jump in and do a
bunch of coding together then we're
going to talk about generative AI um and
then we're going to jump in and do a
bunch of coding together so
um what are we talking about when we're
talking about full step machine learning
we're talking about an engineering
discipline and how to engineer systems
powered by Machine learning okay such as
self-driving cars targeted advertising
fraud detection lead scoring you know
the whole gamut of the types of things
uh we talk about and build okay um so
the question is what type of thing are
we building are we building Cathedrals
where we decide and plan a spe a
specific deliverable um and where we
have to allocate a large amount of time
and resources and perhaps pretend
prepare to uh to spend a long time
building it okay now the results can be
incredible here um but they're
fundamentally static and hard to change
and you can't afford to build too many
of these and as we know with data
powered um software um it can't be
static and it can't be hard to change um
and we need to be able to afford to
build lots of them um in in the name of
experimentation right um because this is
a we're building a scientific discipline
among other things right
so on the other side maybe we want to
start building a bizaar where we invite
people to share their best ideas and
work together as a loose Collective so
there's not high initial investment here
super easy to get started quick to
experiment um with ideas and react to
changing demands so all of these things
sound good
but the results can be limited due to
lack of coordinated and goal oriented in
investment and lack of shared
infrastructure um it's also hard to
maintain results in in the long term so
we kind of want something um between uh
a bizaar and a cathedral right and what
would that look like so one way to think
about it um is um we want to start
building more more Farm likee things
where we have kind of a collective um
you know with shared infrastructure and
shared tooling but people are able to do
things on their own terms as well so
you're able to plan ahead but also react
to results and you can grow in
investment as needed um iterate on best
results and it's this that will produce
long-term long-term value okay um so why
a farm well several reasons first we
want to have a culture of
experimentation so we want all data
scientists and ml Engineers to be to
test a lot of ideas for the applications
they're building um
and we also want to be able to you know
uh nurture all the experiments and now
so that we see actual value or not and a
lot of the time we hear you know 80% of
models or whatever whatever the number
is don't make it to production um as
though that's a bad thing and I don't
think necessarily without more context
we can say if that's a bad thing or not
what what I can say is it's a good thing
if a non-trivial amount a not
insignificant number of um experiments
don't make it to production right
because this is an experimental
discipline um think about science you
know science I mean I've always said
that we need more journals of negative
results right um science is a discipline
that's built on negative and positive uh
results ideally true negatives and true
positives right we know that isn't the
case now unfortunately um but the point
being is that we should be generating
negative results when doing
experimentation um but then we can
double down on the ideas that work okay
um so what do we need to do this uh one
thing we need across an organization um
or any group of people we're trying to
coordinate um or we want coordinated uh
quote unquote uh rowing in the same
direction is common tooling and
infrastructure python right Pi data open
source that's why we're here today right
um and and these things having common
tooling and infrastructure saves time
and effort and makes it easier to
collaborate
um so we'll be talking about um an open
source framework today a lot of the
ideas um will be generalizable to other
Frameworks we'll be talking about an
open source framework today um called
metaflow which was open sourced in 2019
um and by Eddie and my colleagues when
they ran machine learning infrastructure
at Netflix they built it in 2017 open
source in 2019 and has been adopted by
hundreds of companies across many
verticals uh now um so we'll be talking
about metaflow today um and the idea is
that metaflow is something that you can
apply use to apply machine learning to a
lot of different use cases to create uh
machine learning apps easily um to run
you know these apps reliably you need
infrastructure right so this is
something that platform Engineers such
as can build such as uh robust access to
kubernetes clusters or deployment
Frameworks or the these types of things
or scheduled orchestrators
right the these types of things and
we'll get into the nitty-gritty of that
but this is at a high level um what
we're talking about here okay um so yeah
here's a handful of companies such as 23
and me and and Zillow and Carter and
realtor.com and zipline that that use
metaflow uh for just a bit of bit of
social proof If you haven't heard of
metaflow before um so I want to dive a
bit more into what the full stack looks
like um and then we're going to jump in
and start coding okay um
now a question that I think is worth
asking
is once we move
to software powered by data machine
learning and AI does the stack does the
software stack necessarily change um I
think the default answer should be no or
we don't know I think the burden of
proof rests on me for example to
convince you that you need other tools
right um so in the spirit of this let's
think about what we want traditional
software to do and then let's think
about what happens when we introduce
machine learning Ai and data into the
system okay so you can slice your needs
and requirements of traditional software
in a lot of different in a lot of
different ways if I were to rank order
um what I want traditional software to
do um I I think two of the most
important things are we want it to run
reliably without human supervision so
when I close my laptop I can walk away
and go and have dinner and be convinced
that it's still running um we also want
it to produce correct results whoever
our end user and stakeholders are we
want to make sure um that that it isn't
making mistakes for them okay so these
are two of the most important things we
require of traditional
software so what happens to these
requirements when we introduce machine
learning data and AI into software right
so look we have new things we have um we
have data right um we have machine
learning models introduced into the
system system and we even have a new
person next to the data engineer
platform engineer um or infrastructure
engineer or software engineer the data
scientists right um who has a new and
diverse set of skills right which may
not be the same which definitely aren't
the same skills of as the software
engineer I mean I come from a research
uh background right um so let's now
think about how this changes what we
require for the system so these systems
are built around data models and code
right so how do these different parts of
the system interact so for us to use
data for our models we require some sort
of compute that can happen locally on my
local workstation for example my laptop
um or if I'm doing significant compute
maybe I'm using a kubernetes cluster or
something online or something in the
cloud
sorry okay so we definitely require data
compute and models of course now how do
models and code
connect um starting off off maybe you
can do this stuff in a notebook and a
lot of the time you will want to
prototype the types of models you're
building in a notebook but once models
become even slightly sophisticated
you're going to want something more more
robust and you're going to want to build
graphs of models where you have feature
engineering and building different
models and hyperparameter optimization
all of these types of things um and you
may have seen directed ayylic graphs in
data engineering or in machine learning
or orchestration but essentially these
are the types of things that will'll get
to that you'll want to want to build
once you have um slightly more complex
models right so we require
orchestration now the other thing is
these systems are built by humans and
these humans such as myself and Eddie
and most of you here I presume will be
doing rapid prototyping and building
lots of models right so you'll require
versioning and now you know we all know
about versioning of code we've all used
um you know tools such as such as GitHub
for example but now we want to be
versioning data as well uh in in some
ways and versioning models um and these
types of things so the versioning story
expands here um and what I mean by that
is so for example let's say you've got a
machine learning model that does
something wrong down stre it produces a
prediction which like messes something
something up
um let's say you've got a fraud
detection model and it uh incorrectly
classifies something as fraud um or
perhaps worse um does not classify
something that was fraudulent as fraud
and your company
loses um everything goes bankrupt sh
shareholders unhappy you lose your job
um that's you know the one of the
catastrophic situations um no let's not
go that far but let's say it does an
incorrect classification because I was
going to say in that case it doesn't
really matter I right you're not going
to go back and try to find the model
that did it because you don't have a job
um but in the case that um there was an
incorrect classification and you still
have your job um you're going to want to
see which model uh created that and
which run of the model so you want to
have your models versioned and your data
version see what day it happened and
what was the data set that your model
was actually trained on right so the
versioning story is is critical here um
now the final part of the story is
deployment to connect all of this to the
valuable system now this may be you know
your classic rest API your endpoint
you've set up with an application layer
built on top or it may be batch
inference done daily that's updated that
updates um a
database or it may be um you know
deployed via a slide deck that's created
once a week for an executive to consume
um or an email that's sent to the entire
team these these types of things right
so the deployment story can take a lot
of different um flavors let's say it's
not just um an an endpoint which is the
most most common story so what we see
now is that the ml infrastructure stack
um starts with data and then goes up now
through compute orchestration versioning
deployment and modeling on top which you
know all our favorites psyit learns and
XG boosts and Pie torches um and the
truth of the matter is that data
scientists such as us really
fundamentally want to focus on the top
of the stack um yet there's a huge
amount of infrastructure that's required
for the bottom okay um and I just want
to be careful a lot of people say wait
don't data scientists care about the
data and I my response is of course they
do um and what we're really talking
about here is that um this is really the
data engineering layer that makes it uh
consumable for for data scientists so
data scientists may not necessarily care
whether it's coming from Snowflake or
parket shards on S S3 right um but um
the data scientist cares about you know
what the data actually is as opposed to
how it's engineered or what form form
it's in
right um now as we'll get into um
metaflow code um as a lot of other
Frameworks do um looks like this it's
it's objectoriented programming so we're
going to we're going to Define classes
um and we're going to have each step in
the dag um as a a different step using
the at step decorator here so let's just
have a quick look at this code and then
we're going to jump in and start uh
executing code together so at the very
top we have the modeling layer so I'm
specifying um and this is actually you
know part of the pendency management
story which we'll get into but I'm
specifying at um uh entire flow level so
these are steps the entire thing is a
flow what packages I want
okay in terms of deployment um I'm
specifying here that I want this thing
to uh execute daily and essentially I
can also schedule it so that up it up
updates or runs uh whenever data is
updated in an S3 bucket for example or
whenever another flow finishes so were
this an inference or prediction flow I
could have it Tri be triggered by um a
training flow and we'll see examples of
that today as well um the versioning
story um if I want uh variables to
persist throughout a flow and also to be
versioned um okay stored in some
metadata service um I assign it to an
instance variable self self.x um and
just note that we have two steps here we
have a start step and an end step um and
passing self. end self. next in start
tells me um that after start the next
step is the end step okay um the
orchestration story this entire thing is
the orchestration this is how we write
the graph um of the flow in in metaflow
um and perhaps I wonder how we can do
this I'm just wondering how many people
is actually built used orchestrators
before is do you know a way we can ask
this yeah there's a polling feature hug
go do you see the the three vertical
bars I yeah great you while I get up on
the screen do you are you do you think
you could add a question how many people
have used orchestrators before
on i' appreciate that I think it might
take over the screen just FYI but yeah
let me oh amazing well with great power
you know comes you know everything um
now this is one of my favorite Favorite
Things um about meta flow um is the
ability
to let's say I've got like a big
parallel training step that I want to um
that I need to send to Cloud
infrastructure um I can merely uh use
the at kubernetes uh decorator here and
specify how much memory I want of course
this needs to be provisioned for me
we're we're provisioning everything
today um needs to be provisioned for me
otherwise by um you know a platform in
infrastructure engineer but what it
means is as a data scientist or machine
learning engineer I don't have to be
configuring clusters and writing yaml
and all of these types of things in
order to you know start moving from
prototype to production so I can run
this locally and then I can just throw
that decorator on top um in order to
send steps to the cloud so it really
times the loop between prototype and
production as we'll see um and similarly
um you know there are lots of ways to
work with data so where this is a toy
example where we're in incrementing um
our instance variable self.x by one here
um but the data story here is you can
access this is interoperable with all of
your snowflakes and S3s and whatever
else it it may be
um fantastic thanks for setting this up
Eddie I'm answering myself as
well
um it's cool so I can see you know I
can't see the sample size yet but I can
see you
know it's a New Concept to a bunch of
you um so we'll go through exactly what
this looks like um in a minute okay so
we're about to jump in and start coding
what I do want to say as I just
referenced is um we're going to you know
be doing a lot of things to be moving
between prototype and and production and
it isn't this isn't a binary thing okay
it isn't like you deploy something on a
rest API and suddenly you're in ction
and woohoo you know that that isn't the
way way things work um you know um the
graduated approach really is perhaps you
know you're sending things to a cloud
workstation then you're coming back and
exploring with notebooks and you're
creating uh workflows and you're
starting to version things and you're
scaling things vertically and
horizontally then you need rapid data
access then you start to schedule
execution um then you start freezing
your dependencies to make sure it's
robust and then it's like no I need I
need visualization I need I need to be
able to report on my models then I need
to start thinking about AB testing and
then you might think then you're at
production but of course then you need
to debug and and and go back to
prototyping right um so I want I want us
to take a more kind of nuan and holistic
view as to what moving to production
looks like it's this entire process um
and it may involve just you know adding
this kubernetes decorator to access a
cloud workstation as part of going to
production then once you've got some
results there removing it going back
working locally right so this is to to
debug certain things okay um then you
want to freeze dependencies so that your
Cloud workstation has the same packages
that you have have locally right um so
without further Ado um
let's jump in to the sandbox um oh this
is interesting it looks like my tab is
not I need to share my screen again it's
only sharing one tab um and I appreciate
that we've taken around 20 minutes and
we haven't done any coding yet um but
that
was um all in the spirit
of you know setting it up so we know
exactly what we what what we're doing
okay so you can see sandbox now
Eddie looks good great and I'm looking
at the poll so we do it does look you
know pretty much 50/50 actually for more
people it's a New Concept um what's the
sample size I can't can't see can you uh
yeah we're at about 20 votes so okay
cool insignificant but not nothing it's
it's yeah I can you actually see how
many people are in the session by any
J um oh now we got more votes coming in
um
okay I can't give you an exact count I'd
estimate about 80 maybe 70 80 looking at
the thank you all for for being here
it's a true pleasure to you know be
teaching so many in interested and
excited people who I mean mostly doing
this out of their own work time as well
so
anyway what I want to do is to um jump
into the the sandbox so to be clear
I've just shown you a bunch of
infrastructure you need to kind of get
started with full stack machine learning
and the question is how on Earth can we
just open a collab notebook and have
access to this infrastructure and the
answer is definitively no so what we've
done is we've um we've we've built a
Sandbox that um in which we can
provision everything for you to get up
and running with with this stuff okay so
what I want you to do is to click on the
sandbox link um and you can log in with
um Gmail or GitHub it's totally totally
up to you
um and um if you want to hear more about
sandbox stuff and news uh feel free to
leave this thing click down here but if
you unclick it you'll never hear hear
from us so I just want to make clear um
that we Our intention is not to spam you
at all or anything along those lines
okay so as and Eddie would you mind
actually actually creating one more poll
of like did you get into the sandbox
successfully
um and so here up we have our data
scientists accessing data this is a
little story that that we're telling
here to get you ready for the sandbox
data and orchestration and having these
two things connected and then versioning
um you're requiring all these things
compute and deployment right so we need
all these things connected um and this
is what we're providing for you here so
essentially you can think of it as
Google collab for the full stack of
machine learning infrastructure another
way to think about it is that it's um a
superpowered uh vs code right um so if
you've used uh Visual Studio code before
which is a really cool way I mean I so
I'm not sponsored by Microsoft in any
way um nor do I think I can't even see
a a a not so distant future in which I
am sponsored by by by Microsoft um but
anyway um uh I'm a big fan of vs code
for for veloping C and ml systems so
we've built this in the browser which
essentially
um um what we see is you know our
regular um scripts here our terminal
here we've got our local file system
here we have another little thing here
which is a table of contents and then
for each exercise we have um some notes
here okay um the other thing is for some
reason these um icons should say things
but they they don't currently um Eddie
is there a way I can do you know what
yeah H I just sent you a link you're on
an old sandbox version right now um I
just sent you a link in the
chat great in which
chat um the second icon if you look on
the panel on the right side of there's a
second ion in our
slack great thanks so much man
thank you all for bearing with
us fantastic okay cool um so I just want
to make sure I'm just going to go back
to um the poll
[Music]
and yes I am able to to access the
sandbox great for those who say no um if
you want to pop if you actually can't do
it pop um in the in the general chat um
don't Eddie will do his best to help out
don't DM him um because the intention is
that other people may be able to help as
well um so without further Ado though
I'm going to jump in and we want to
start start writing or executing these
flows okay
so um we've seen what a flow looks like
um as a first flow um what I'm going to
do is create one which has a start step
an eat step um because I'm hungry and an
end step always good to give workshops
when you're slightly slightly hungry not
too hungry but definitely not full um
okay now metaflow doesn't put a lot of
constraints around um how you write your
flows we do do want you to start with a
start step and end with an end step and
do pretty much anything in the middle um
the one other thing we kind of require
is that if you branch and we'll see what
branching is um to do things in parallel
that then you join them back together
right and then wrap up with an endep so
how do we run these flows so you can
click run but what this actually does is
I'm just going to have a look
at
um in here
um essentially what this does is all you
need to do to run code is write python
uh then the name of the flow and this is
in so the directory this is in is hello
and it's flow.
py
so so I do python path to flow and name
of flow and then
run
ahuh ah I did some we indent there okay
let's try this
again okay cool so we're seeing some
output
um pilent has just check checked our
code uh then we're creating a local data
store which is where all our metadata
will be stored um then the workflow is
starting and we'll look at the UI in a
second then we'll see that the start
step is running um this means it's the
first run essentially um then the E step
then the end step um and it's
successfully done and we'll see on the
right so if you're able to do this you
just executed the workflow um right and
um if you look closely you can see the
correspondence between the code on the
left the output in the terminal and here
that we have a start step an eat step
and an end step so all this is is is the
graph we're talking about we've just
orchestrated this graph um in code and
then executed it using metaflow as such
okay um and what I want us to do now is
to look at the UI here you can copy and
paste this URL or you can go here and
click on this and this will
open the metaphor
UI so here we see we've run our first
flow which is hello flow click on that
and we'll we have our progress bars
essentially so we have the start step e
step end step very cool you click on dag
start eat end um there are lots of
different things there um and what we'll
see here is nothing at the moment but
when you start creating custom
visualizations we can actually have um
cards which tell us a lot of things
about what's happening in in in our
models any anything you want essentially
you can build your own cards so um
without further Ado let's go to the next
one and instead of writing um python
name of flow uh run in the command line
I'm actually going to do this do this
here um we also I don't know whether
someone has asked this but we get a
common question so where we're doing
this all um in the sandbox because we're
about to access kubernetes clusters and
that type of stuff we've had this UI so
this is how we've set it up for you um
if you want to set up similar things for
yourself uh locally or at home or at
work um Eddie would you mind just
linking to the engineering docs um so
that people can get a sense of of how to
do this now to be clear um it isn't like
you or I can just set up this stuff in
an hour right there's a huge amount of
infrastructure that goes into this type
of stuff but Eddie will provide
resources that if you want to take this
to work or do this yourself and have fun
doing it um you can
so let's have a look what we've run
here so you might notice that there's
not a big difference between code we've
run before um and this code except step
the start step we're actually passing
two new steps to it here okay so the
self. next we're telling it the next
steps are eat and drink then we Define
eat then we Define drink and we're
settling both of them that the next step
will be self. jooin that's
exactly what we see what we see here um
now um You may say why would you do this
and I say well if they're independent
steps um it helps um in terms of time
essentially to parallelize it right and
what we'll see here is that you know we
each of these steps we slept for 10
seconds and we'll see that in total it
actually took uh 12 seconds um and the
couple of extra seconds it took
um uh yeah because we needed to start
and finish individual tasks which uh
metaflow executes as um separate
processes um and if you want to you know
verify that this is actually what's
happening you can you can change these
yourself and see well let's just go go
back to our metaphor UI and see yeah
these things have happened in parallel
um exactly as as just stated and in the
dag we see that as well
okay
um so now when thinking through um
artifacts these are things stored from
from flows and and versioning as I
mentioned um if we hadn't assigned five
to an instance variable it wouldn't be
passed through steps so now what we're
doing is we're assigning it to the
instance variable and as we see here
when executed uh the value of x is six
okay um and we see that see that come up
there um so let's just have one more
look in the UI and see this that's
exactly what we
thought would
happen
um I think once again yet we haven't
built any cards so things are looking
looking okay there um but this is
essentially to show you how to pass
things between between steps um and I
know we haven't quite got to machine
learning yet um but this is all in the
name of setting up uh the basic building
blocks so when we get to machine
learning it all falls into
place
um
so in this step in this this flow what
we're doing
is we'll be um doing parall processing
so we saw how we could Branch uh before
by passing um several steps to
self. what if you have a thousand steps
though um then it you don't necessarily
want to pass them all and then hand code
them all right um so what we can do to
achieve that is um to pass to self. next
um what the ne the name of the next step
will be and then um uh for each and then
giving it a list so this list is two um
but we could could make it three or four
or or however many you want and actually
um let me
um add another to it and
see um and then in process essentially
what we're doing um maybe Eddie you want
to say a bit about um what we're doing
here um with to the next step in in
order to get the
result yeah sure so it looks like we're
taking the input from the previous step
um so that this self. input variable is
getting attached um and the way that
that is coming from metaflow is that the
four each that Hugo is just describing
they each have a unique piece of data so
we're going to make three in this case
process tasks and those process tasks
are coming from the self. dat that we
split the for each on that's the input
in the process step and then we're going
to do something on that Shard of the
data if you will um so in this case it
looks like we're just assigning it to
self. fruit getting the length and then
um that's our
score super cool thanks Eddie um and
you'll see how reactive our guey is here
um sorry our card um that we're able to
you know I changed it and it told me
about the blueberry process happening
happening
there so I'm going to click run on the
next flow because it will take a second
cuz we're scaling to the cloud and then
take us back to the metaflow UI and
we'll have a look at the scale Ah that's
the flow happening now the 4 flow we'll
see yeah these are the three so you know
your Apple orange and blueberry right um
so going back here let's just have a
look what's happening differently here
so we have apple orange and watermelon
we're doing for each we're doing the
same thing um and then the process step
is similar or the same actually um but
if this process step is going to take
significant computation we send it to
the cloud as I mentioned
previously what you need to do is add
the at kubernetes decorator to it okay
and that's essentially all we've done
there um and then
um we're joining um and then we've got
our endstep so we can see um these tasks
are starting now so there is some um you
know time debt in terms of like startup
startup time now for these so you know
the developer time is reduced a lot um
but as with all Cloud infrastructure we
require startup time up up there so once
again don't think that because develop
time is reduced this is something you
should leverage all the time um but only
when when necessary right um so let's
just go back to our UI while that flows
running and we can
see yep the processes happen in parallel
we have these memory hog steps which you
can you know we haven't done this
because it'll take more time but you can
uncomment them in order to um you know
do more computation
essentially um and it looks like we've
ended now and we just had a look in the
UI why don't we have a look at the dag
as well yep and we'll see um because
we've um paralled ized over several
things it kind of puts the cards on top
of each other to suggest that um it's
parallelized as opposed to spelling them
all out and you can full screen this if
you
want now we're getting to some pretty
exciting things so we're going to do
production ready environments then
machine learning and action then
deploying workflows to production or
reactive machine learning um and then
we're going to jump into the generative
AI section of this uh Workshop okay so
I'm going to run this flow
and the reason I'm doing that is because
it's going to take a while to bootstrap
the cond environment um and while we're
doing that I want to tell you what we're
doing so um we're starting to move more
in this graduated approach to machine
learning let's just go back here for a
second um to a few of the things that
are happening here um so what are we
doing well no no no no um we're freezing
Library dependencies we're validating
results as a separate step and we're
creating custom report cards okay so
we're adding some reporting we're
freezing uh dependencies okay um and
adding some some validation right um so
let's just have a look um at at the code
okay so we're looking at the New York
City Taxi data set which you may recall
um if you've seen it we're say this from
um S3 from parket file is on different
days of the week talks about start and
end time terms of U taxi trips in
Manhattan
um prices tips these types of things
right we're going to look at it over a
variety of of different days and what
we're going to do here what we're doing
here is we're actually uh performing the
visualization
so in order to specify what packages we
want um we want particular versions of
particular packages right so what we
want is we want particular version of
data Shader for visualization some of
our um data wrangling we want a
particular version of pandis we want pi
Arrow we want numpy as well okay um so
then let's have a look at what we're
doing
um so one thing is we've seen you know
steps um we've seen flow flow specs
which is what we're subclassing to
create these flows we haven't seen um
parameters yet so maybe Eddie you'd like
to say a word or two about parameters in
metapo yeah yeah sure um so parameters
are a way to bring data into the
workflow from the command line when you
run it um so if we're in this case where
we're kind of manually running it like
Hugo's been doing here maybe there's a
file that we want to pass in um into the
workflow maybe there's some parameter
that we want to use to kind of determine
how we split the data Maybe it could
even be the thing that determines how we
do the for each as he was showing last
time um so there's a bunch of different
ways you can do it it can be kind of an
arbitrary python object essentially that
you can pass into the workflow um and
then this becomes a superpower as he go
will kind of lead you towards in the in
the remaining parts of this session at
at the deployment time when these
workflows maybe we're not manually
running them anymore we want we want to
deploy them into the cloud and then we
need to pass some new data into the flow
um and we we don't even know what that
data is until the production system
generates it exactly thanks so much for
that context deddie um so we're having a
start step where we're doing some
wrangling uh then we're having a
visualized step and we're using the at
card decorator right in order to do this
visualization and we'll see what that
looks like in our cards then we're doing
our validation step um and then we're
doing our end step and you'll see that
we're doing all these plotting steps now
um right that these are happening we've
started them all they're plotting now so
they should be happening in parallel in
the UI uh let's see
sick right y having all these visualized
steps happen in parallel we can see our
visualization is happening now which our
validation I'm
sorry and we're wrapping up okay so I
want to show you the visualizations uh
in a second what I'm going to do is um
actually we're not going to talk through
so much of this um I I will say that
we've used atondo base to specify
dependencies at a flow level you can use
atondo to specify them at um Step level
and we also have an at pip at Pipi
decorator which allows you to do all
this stuff using pip as well but what I
want to do before showing you the VIS
visualizations is run the next flow just
because it'll take a minute or two as as
well um while we while we look at these
so if we go to the dag we can see once
we've got again we've got start
visualize validate end if we got to
tasks
um right we see we've got a lot of
things happening here including our
artifacts um now if
we if we go to validate which is where
we've pulled all these um visual
visualizations together what we can see
is that we've got our visualizations of
Taxi drop off locations by weekday so we
have it on Sunday Monday
Tuesday and so on right now they may not
look
that that different um and I suppose
maybe you want to do some normalization
of the heat map um in order to see if
there are any differences that type of
stuff um a few things you can see though
is firstly you can see the outline of
Manhattan
right so um and of course actually it
isn't only Manhattan we're having trips
in Queens and and Brooklyn down here as
well um you can see Central Park emerged
there are um very few taxi drop drop
offs I mean there are a couple of PS
through here and you can see a lot of H
action happening um in
Midtown uh Manhattan um it looks like
there's more happening on Friday
I I'm surprised that there isn't more
happening a bit further downtown as as
well but you know maybe that's that's my
bias um okay anyway um the short version
the tldr is that we've created this
visualization but you can create any
visualization you want you can have
model reporting cards you can have um
you know accuracy plots you can put
confusion matrices whatever you want to
communicate um to yourself and your and
your stakeholders okay um
so let's now have a look at what we're
doing here this is great so now we're
actually um building a model um on over
a million data points here so what we're
trying to do is we're we're trying to uh
predict um it's a fair regression flow
so predict the taxi fair uh based on a
number of features right um so the
features we're taking out are year day
of week hour absolute distance longitude
um of pickup and longitude of drop off
right um so in the start step we're
reading in our parket and we're doing
our train ah sorry we've done our train
test split in terms of our our
parameters um then we're setting our
training data
set and our test data set then we're
instantiating and fitting uh a random
Forest in The Next Step um then we're
you know we're importing doing our
Imports at a at a step level um and
recognize that maybe you don't want to
import pandis isn't a small package
right maybe you don't want to be
importing it every step so importing
this at a step level um and doing our
prediction then um going through what
um Computing our metric so our root mean
squ error and the model one and then the
Baseline B one and then we're creating a
custom report um which will appear as
the cards did before um right and uh
then where we've got our endep and we
had a make random Forest function we uh
used above um and we've actually defined
that below and this is something and our
plot as well this is something that I
want to make clear is that you know as
you build more complex flows you're not
going to want to include all your code
in every in in in your flow right so you
may want to put this in a utils in the
end right um or you know actually you
know write a small package yourself or
something along those lines we've all
done it in here for pedagogical purposes
but um I wonder Eddie um I know this is
kind of a whirlwind tool but there's
anything you want to add about decou
decoupling computation logic from
business logic or any any of these
things when when writing writing flows
sure sure um I think it's a good idea in
many cases um yeah it's often useful to
kind of separate the machine learning
code and the business logic and the
experimentation code from the actual
workflow system that's going to do
things like package up environments and
run them on kubernetes compute nodes
things like this um one reason is that
maybe you want to develop these kinds of
things in a Jupiter notebook or some
kind of workstation that's that's very
unlike in some ways the automated system
you want to run it on in production um
so it can be useful to kind of separate
that piece so you can run it independent
of the workflow system and then
seamlessly plug it into a system like
metaflow when you want to actually go Mo
move this from development to
production um many other things that we
could say there but I don't want to
break your train of thought too much you
go appreciate it man um and and love all
that
context so now great timing this run has
finished um so actually Hugo would you
mind if I interjected quickly Lou asked
an excellent qu set of questions really
and I think it'd be good for everyone to
hear be cool if we yeah read it out loud
let's do that I do want to say quickly
though if you this is interesting um if
you see these are flows that you have
not seen me run um and Eddie's actually
running flows in my account um for the
next part of the workshop as as well
that's a that's a little teaser I do
want to get to lose questions let's just
have a quick look um at the figures
generated um to wrap up this section
we've got our create report so we've
gone down to task go down to create
report wait a
sec and we'll see this is um what what
we've seen so the correct fair is on the
x axis predicted Fair um and then this
is the line X is equal to Y so we see
you know it's looking not horrible for a
lot of it um we have some weird weird
bands here which we'd want to want to
check out um but my point isn't really
to diagnose the model we built but
rather the show how you can quickly
build visualizations in order order to
to do so um so yeah Eddie let's
let's get to these questions I haven't
seen them yet oh yeah amazing
questions um Eddie maybe you want to ask
the question and then answer it yeah
sure um does metlow work with kubernetes
cluster that also runs non-ml
Services um so very good question for
many reasons short answer is yes you can
use any kubernetes cluster as the
compute environment to run these Metal
Flow tasks where you see Hugo kind of
ADD and these tasks with at
kubernetes um so yeah that that's the
short answer um I mean there's there's
obviously some reasons why maybe you
would want to have multiple clusters at
a large organization um but that's maybe
beyond the scope of of this question for
now um if you're curious about that
though we'd love to have discussions
like that that are much more in-depth on
these things on the outerbound slack um
some other stuff that's more on the data
science layer then is there a way to
compare results between different runs
with cards
um Hugo I've seen people doing this in
notebooks because you can fetch all
these cards in notebooks have you seen
any other ways that people are kind of
comparing different runs of the same
flow to kind of like C cards in
comparison like this
um yes so I think notebooks is the first
place to do and we haven't done a lot of
that today to be honest we haven't done
a lot of work with the client API right
in this in this Workshop um so maybe you
can link to some resources there the
first thing think comping runs um is to
there's we've got a really nice client
API which allows you to either from the
command line or in notebooks um quickly
have a look at runs you've just done and
this is in kind of the spirit of moving
between prototype and production right
and then once you've run some models
then you want to go back to
experimentation and kind of treat the
models you've run kind of like data in a
lot of ways right um so you can do that
in um in a notebook which is the first
way to do it once you have a robust way
of doing that then putting that in cards
is is really nice um so this is once
again something we we're not covering
today but we'd love to chat about it and
in fact let me just
um you know I don't want
to
um I'm going to put this link in now if
these are the types of things we talk a
lot about on our community slack as well
so I've just included the link to our
slack and the the Q&A um but if you're
AB testing uh models for example um um
you can then look at the results of your
ab tests in um in notebooks or you can
go to cards and build cards that can
allow you to rapidly look at them as
well so the short answer is first tried
in notebooks and then move to cards
absolutely um now Ross has an incredible
question um does metaflow replace the
need for both prefect or airflow and DVC
which is data versioning and an
experiment tracking um so I I'll say a
few things about that but then I'll pass
pass it over to Eddie um I I would never
say metaflow replaces um any of these
tools you can use them together um in a
lot of ways but the way I think about it
is that airflow um is something that a
lot of organizations already use for
data engineering and we would not
suggest you come in and start using
metaflow for that if you're building
things from the ground up you can
definitely consider using metlow for all
of these things but we prefer to think
of you being able to interoperate with
them so metaflow and airflow have always
you've always been able to do kind of
bespoke Integrations right um but um
what I wanted to show you is that and
I'll actually share a link to this as
well
um and you can look look into this but
we spent a lot of time with the people
at airflow actually integrating airflow
and and metaflow to make sure that when
all your data engineering um happens in
airflow that then you can pass things to
um uh uh metaflow in order to schedule
and orchestrate everything on the
machine learning side as well um so
Eddie I wonder if you want to say a bit
more about this
also yeah I think I think Hugo hit the
nail on the head um from my point of
view I I suppose on a technical layer
um technically any of these tools can
run arbitrary python code so in some
sense it's like if if you really just
are looking to replace tools any of
these tools with any of the other ones
you could do it um I would I would say
that metaflow is more focused on the
kind of data science machine learning
workflows and just kind of running more
General python code where prefect and
airflow tend to focus on data
engineering specific things um that
that's kind of what I've heard from
other folks and I'm not really an expert
in airflow or prefect so that's kind of
where I get most of my knowledge is just
through listening to our customers and
the open source Community um in terms of
the DVC question I think metap
versioning is doing something quite a
bit different um we're more talking
about versioning of workflows and
versioning of the artifacts that those
workflows produce whereas DVC is more
trying to bring this kind of git like
Version Control to the data sets that
that these like large training data sets
themselves um metap can certainly work
with a tool like DBC that's doing that
but metap isn't directly handling that
kind of versioning um where where you
might want to be like looking at like S3
bucket versioning or something over over
a long period of time for a huge
training data set um exactly you could
definitely build them in together but
yeah not not really directly over that
with
DVC thanks so much Eddie um so in use of
time I want to wrap up this section but
with a very important thing this is
starting to think about how to deploy
workflows right so we've
um so far we've developed and tested
workflows locally run them in the cloud
um but one if I want to go and close my
laptop we want this to run without human
supervision right if I want to close my
laptop and make sure it's still
running then I need to deploy it right
um so metaflow interoperates with a lot
of different production schedulers
perhaps you's used AWS step functions
right um there are lots of different
ones you you you can do but all of these
will ensure the flow executes um
automatically in a highly available
manner um where we we're deploying this
to uh one called um it's a cloud native
um uh workflow scheduler called Argo
which is incredibly robust and and works
incredibly well with kubernetes which is
one of the reasons that we that that
we're using it using it here um but what
I've done here you'll see is all I've
needed to do is change python name of
flow run to python name of flow Argo
workflows create okay you can do that by
clicking deploy flow um the other the
only other change we're making is we're
adding an at trigger decorator to the
entire flow which will specify how we're
going to actually so we've created this
flow we haven't triggered it so it's not
running yet we've deployed it but not
triggered it okay um so this will tell
us how we actually uh trigger it and so
there are lots of ways to do this we're
going to do it in two ways I'm going to
trigger it by
actually now instead of python flow. py
AO workflows create we can do ago
workflows trigger and this will trigger
it and I'll in a second go to the Argo
UI to actually show you that
so this is our little Argo logo you can
click on that to go to the Argo UI
um and what we'll
see here is so these are some other ones
Eddie is run that let's not worry about
at the moment but this is event
triggered flow we can see when you
there's lots of stuff here the two
things I want you to know are the
workflow templates this is the one that
we've this happens when we create it you
click on it you can see all this yaml
now this is something metaflow does for
you you've ridden the flow it converts
it into the yaml that um Argo or any
other scheduler will will will require
right so you don't need to worry about
that so much these are the templates and
these are the actual workflows here so
let's continue and we can see that we've
actually triggered the flow and we can
see we're having we're starting it it
will end soon because we've just got a
start and an end step okay um so
essentially once that's triggered it's
there in in production okay and I Clos
my laptop and it's still there similarly
um if while it was running I closed my
laptop and it still be there similarly
if I've got an inference flow prediction
flow that then um or a trained model I'm
sorry that I want to um I'm sorry no a
prediction flow that I'm having
production then I can set up a rest
point that people can ping when I go and
close my laptop and all all of these
types of things right um
so the other way to trigger it is
because
I've you know got the at trigger
decorator with um events that I can pass
to
it I can um
you know uh execute this code from the
command line um or from a notebook in
order to trigger uh another run
so let's do that and we can see um you
know these are the types of things that
that are happening we have some event
and and maybe data uploading right um or
being added to S3 or data warehouse or
whatever it is to trigger trigger this
flow so what we should see is
essentially another run-of this flow
triggered that's exactly what we've done
you can also use chronik syntax in order
to schedule these as as essentially cron
jobs right which will run you know at
any you know regular Cadence or
irregular Cadence that that you want
also okay um so yeah I think that's all
I want to say there because we do want
to jump in and I I'd wanted maybe 45
minutes for this next session but we'll
do a kind of a warwind tour we have
promised to do some some generative AI
stuff today um before doing that I will
say we're going to do some stuff with
large language models um if you are
interested in other types of
um um uh generative AI models and
Foundation models with uh metaflow um
and how we think about it uh you can
have a look at our foundation model
section of our uh blog where we have all
types of llm stuff um um we have um all
types of you know uh speech to text and
then stable diffusion and actually if um
if you join us on slack in the next few
days we're going to publish our work
that we're doing on stable video
diffusion um which Eddie and I are
having had huge amount of fun with
aren't we Eddie oh
yeah um so that's that's super cool
um so without further Ado let's have a
quick chat about full stack generative
AI um and then jump into the sandbox
again to check out some code
so
um we won't go into too many details now
but in a lot of ways the full stack of
generative AI um the stack doesn't
change so much compared to machine
learning um except it kind of gets
squeezed in or pinched let's say that
people even care more about modeling now
because they gener want to want to
generate value using using the models
ASAP with these incredible models but we
actually require even more in
infrastructure like you may be aware of
the stuff we need at the compute layer
right but we need you know we need a lot
more sophisticated work with data
because there is a lot more data in in a
lot of ways flows are increasingly
complex when we're generating you know
with llms unstructured text constantly
um unstructured data well I mean natural
language is structured in some ways but
non-tabular data we need to think more
robustly about the versioning story
there as well um so we're thinking more
about the types of systems we can build
here and I want to say a few words about
that um where you know let's say for
example you have um a customer service
chatbot right where you're taking maybe
a model from the Llama family right an
open source Foundation model uh you're
fine-tuning it generating embeddings
that allow you then to build a custom
from a service chatbot um you've got
some of your own data coming in from a
data warehouse there similarly these llm
Bings are feeding into personalized
recommendations with stuff coming from
the data warehouse that are going to
another product um but the product
requires image generation as well and
you're actually using a vendor API to do
that to generate the images getting
stuff from your data warehouse sending
stuff to cloud storage then serving that
into the product right so this is one
schematic the types of things you could
you could be building right um there are
lots of things you want to figure out
here but one is where your governance
boundary is as well so you can govern
everything you have internally here um
but your open source Foundation model
perhaps you don't have access to the
data it was trained on right you only
have the weights or these types of
things the AI vendor API is definitely
outside your governance boundary so you
have no control over latency or certain
aspects of privacy of things you're
sending there and these these types of
things so you really want to think about
what type of risk you're taking on um
maybe you know you could even um be
using a vendor that you know May Fire a
CEO and then re rehire him um like I I
don't know if that would ever happen um
in this space at all I mean I'm not
referring to any recent events at all
but you you definitely want to think
about what type of risk you're adopting
when you're using uh getting locked into
to specific vendors as well right all
all jokes
aside um so we're going to jump into to
uh generic large language well sorry
into large language models now the
reason we've chosen this is we've assume
that everyone's kind of familiar with
chat GPT or these types of things where
essentially they're conversational
interfaces um and then we're going to
jump into just thinking through um how
we can use these to build products
quickly and how uh meta flow and these
types of things can can help you with
that so Eddie maybe you can say a few
words about generic llms and then we can
move on to you know fine-tuning and then
uh Rags as
well sure thing
um yeah so this this picture is
essentially describing the case of using
something like chat GPT exactly as heo
said we have a prompt going into the
model we have this kind of big generic
model that's kind of this Big Blob
compressing a large portion of the
internet into some ability to kind of
keep predicting the next token based on
what it's already seen um and then that
thing is eventually going to Output some
response and our goal is to increase the
relevance of that response so so that's
kind of the whole project that we're
going on for the rest of this session
and this is our Baseline of just typing
something into chat GPT the thing that
we type in as a user is obviously very
relevant to what we care about um and
then we kind of are getting this
variable relevance as the output because
the generic model is just it's that it's
generic it's it's the most General thing
it's kind of an average in some ways of
the internet in a lot of ways um so then
as we keep moving forward the goal is
going to be to increase the relevance of
that output through some clever
techniques um called retrieval augmented
generation is kind of a blanket term
exactly and so the example we'll
actually be doing is metaflow
documentation so we're going to ask it
how do you specify dependencies right
which is something we've talked about
using atcond base or atcond at a step
level right whereas if you went into um
let's say you just wanted to ask chat
gbt how do I specify dependencies for a
flow or something it'll probably tell
you something um General about uh cond
um or maybe virtual environments or pip
um without being specific to metaflow so
when we're thinking about documentation
um and conversational interfaces for
getting information around our open
source framework um you know this is
actually incredibly quote unquote
relevant so that's what we'll be doing
now
um so what what's one way to to approach
this
any yeah I think the most common way
that people approach it with and the the
best way to get started in my opinion is
prompt engineering is kind of the
blanket term um which is essentially
just including more relevant information
in the prompt itself um so kind of the
same model we're not changing anything
about the interface we're not changing
anything about the prompt Beyond just
structuring it in a more useful way the
way I think of this is kind of like how
there's ways that you can interact with
Google search as well where you just
type things into the command line in a
certain way that makes Google more
likely to kind of surface the sort of
results that you're that you're looking
for um same thing exists with these
large language models um both in
positive and negative ways by the way
there's like a lot of security issues
with the negative ways that people are
doing this around like jailbreaks and
things but the core idea here is just
like more relevant information in the
input that we show to the llm can
improve the relevance as a as like a
baseline idea to keep improving
on um but today we'll be going through
an example of retrieval augmented
generation right exactly um
so similar to to The Prompt engineering
case some people might even consider
this sort of a special case of prompt
engineering the rag retrieval elemented
generation what we're doing is taking
the prompt from the user and say
matching it against some similar inputs
and we'll talk about what I mean by
similar in great detail for the rest of
this presentation and then using those
similar inputs that are in a database
that we consider like that Hugo and I
say consider factual data as app
designers or kind of people governing
the product that's that's using this
system those relevant um kind of factual
responses from the context database are
then going to increase the prompt even
more um the excuse me increase the
relevance of the prompt even more and
then ideally keep kind of boosting the
ultimate relevance of this endtoend
generation pipeline exactly so um so as
Eddie said we're going to help the model
by adding relevant information um but
how should we find the relevant
information in the first place so Eddie
maybe you can tell us a bit about the
type of vectors we're creating and then
we can jump in and have a
look yeah um so super quick we can just
kind of imagine I mean the llms
themselves are basically just like
massive pools of um com compressed
information from web pages in large part
um so you can imagine a bunch of
documents like web pages or pages in a
book or pages from the metaflow
documentation which we'll show later um
you can embed these things through some
mathematical function and convert each
of the documents to a vector very common
in machine learning it's like not not A
New Concept at all and then at runtime
or the inference time we can do the same
exact thing with the user's query or
some kind of post-processed version of
it and we can get a new vector and then
we can run a search process some
similarity search through a something
like a cosine similarity or any way to
compare two vectors together and then we
can use that to produce some list of
relevant results in the third step at
the bottom of this
picture awesome um so we can get more
into like how that interacts with the
app and stuff but yeah think you go
further Ado let's let's jump in and
Eddie do you w to um oh yeah so we're
going to jump into the sandbox again
it's going to be a different instance of
the sandbox um let me
see so firstly um we do have a blog post
on these types of things and it's uh
more more comprehensive than what we'll
cover here we don't have time to cover
everything in this but this kind of
we'll be going through the retrieval
augmented Generation stuff here but this
goes through you know commercial apis
prompt engineering fine-tuning um but
we'll be going through rags and then
building rag rag systems using using
metaflow um and
um so I'm going
to open my new workspace what I'm going
to get you to do now I do not suggest
you code
in code along here um because we have
around 15 minutes left we're going to
kind of go through um the code I won't
be executing it um it takes more time
this is a repository um for a workshop
we gave recently um in in Austin um and
you can set up
your um sandbox to using these setup
instr instructions in order to have
access to um everything that I'm doing
here as as well
um right and this is what it should look
like but for example the setup you have
to do in Notebook one um may take five
minutes or so right so um in the
interest of time um we're going to jump
right down to Rag and Vector databases
and we have everything there that's
fantastic um so we're going to go
through this uh relatively quickly um
just to give you a sense of how this all
works and you know an exercise for you
later is to jump in and play around with
it a lot with your um self um but so the
question is and then we're going to show
how to use metap and Argo to deploy it
um question is how can we use your own
unstructured data like blog posts data
like blog posts documentation and videos
video collections to inform large
language models so we've got all this
data we want to chunk it put it into
chunks right then compute embeddings on
the chunks using a model so put it in
some high dimensional Vector space then
we want to index them in some way so
they're retrievable can use Vector
databases or things like this whatever
it is um then based on user queries so
let's say I say ask a question about
metaflow I want to have a look at
similarity Searchers on this query
against the embeddings and Eddie
mentioned we can use something like
cosine similarity we haven't heard of
that before it's essentially you've got
two vectors like if you can see my video
pointing like this and some angle
between them cosine similarity is the
cause cosine of that angle essentially
or some normalized version of it so if
they're closer it's larger if they're um
further away it's smaller okay so that's
generally how how how we're thinking
thinking about things here um then we'll
return the top cage most similar vectors
and then decode the vectors into the
original data format um right so you
know this is a high level overview of
what we're doing here um but let's jump
in and see how this actually works okay
um so we need to chunk the data and
upload the embedded chunks into Vector
storage now in in order to kind of give
you kind of a bit of knowledge around
production tools here and you I mean one
of the big challenges in this space is
latency so we want to get things as
quickly as possible um we thought to
mention a variety of Open Source and and
uh commercial Solutions here so there
are a bunch here we're going to jump in
and use pine cone um to guide our
example in this notebook uh you install
your dependencies here we've got a pine
cone API key and an open a AI key um
I've put these in the notebook uh for
demo purposes uh do not put Keys
directly in
notebooks ever or maybe just when you're
work working by yourself but it's really
easy to forget that you want to use
environment variables for the most part
or something like metaflow Secrets which
Eddie may may link to If he if he has it
up um which allows you to you know
safely and securely store all all your
types of um Secrets including Keys um
then what we're doing here is we're
uploading uh the index um okay and then
where so we're doing a a toy example
here we're taking three text samples um
which
um we will then compare to questions
around metaflow right so hello gen
friends metaflow helps you build
production ml workflows then lots of
people recognize ml systems require
robust workflows and you may expect that
when we have a look at metaflow queries
against these samples that the ca
similarity should be pretty high for
this then maybe a bit less for this then
a bit less but still positive
potentially still correlated with with
that one okay so then how do we think
about embedding these and I appreciate
we're moving quite quickly here and that
there's perhaps an impedance mismatch
between the sophistication or the
complexity of the earlier onboarding
lesson we we did with with um in the
soundbox but the intention here is to
show you more production stuff to wrap
up this this class as well so you have a
lot more to work with and anything you
want to find out more about this please
do come and join us on slack as uh as
well um so what we're doing here is
we're taking um a Transformer model from
hugging face in order to embed um these
um Tech samples in Vector embeddings in
high dimensional space um then we're
going to create our pine cone index um
then we're going to upsert which is a
common term for essentially inserting um
our uh Tech sample embeddings into
the database is that the best way to
explain upsert
Eddie yeah it's really it's it's similar
to an insert operation um minor
difference but not a big deal um and
then we're doing our query what does
metaflow do and then we're going to
compare it um to the top three um and
Eddie if I execute matches now should I
be able to
see um yeah I think so um
looks like you still yeah use the pi
data one there oh it looks like the
cells would need to get re-executed
again so since we only have 10 minutes
maybe it's not the best use to run
everything above so what you'll see here
everyone when you run this is that um
the matches actually because it will
take too too much time um the matches
you'll see that um as I said uh what
does metaflow do we have a relatively
High cosine similarity
uh to this slightly lower for this one
and then slightly lower for that one is
that correct Eddie yeah that should be
right yeah y sorry about that maybe the
next oh no yeah there's nothing there
okay um great so so this was a toy
example right
um but now we want to kind of upload all
the metap documentation to be able to
query it right um so what we're doing is
we're going take this repository path
which is the metapo docs under the
Netflix's um uh
repo we're going to take everything in
there um and convert into a data frame
and do a bit of filtering um and then
we'll just have a look at the data frame
and we'll see we have headers we have
contents which is some form of
HTML um then we have the page URL uh
character count uh word count few other
things right um so as we previously did
we're going to create these embeddings
right we're going see the dimension is
384 uh then we're going to create our
index and then we're going to upsert
everything in there okay um so um now
we've done that we want
to then use this rag system with our
um with a generic llm such as cat gbt um
in order to see whether it helps us
answer our question now how how do we
know if it's going to help us answer our
question we need some form of Benchmark
so this is what I mentioned before what
we're doing is we're going to ask chat
gbt essentially
um the the query that we defined here
how do I specify cond dependencies in my
flow we're not mentioning meta flow and
as I said before yeah so chat jbt is
saying to specify cond dependencies in
your flow you create an n. yaml um and
then you do yada yada yada okay um and
it actually this is cool it gives um
gives a prefect ex example is four right
um but this doesn't answer our
question um and nor nor should it answer
our question right because we haven't
added our documentation to it yet so
let's now actually do that so remember
we talked about how many um you know
things from our rag from our uh document
we want want to retrieve um we're going
to choose five um and this is a design
choice and this you should really think
about how many you choose when you're
designing your application um uh but
we're going to choose five for for for
the for the time
being um and so we're going to embed and
match our search Vector let's look at
the five that we retrieved and we see
it's compatibility with cond pii cond
decorator is great condo base tring
across brancher disabling environments
that looks pretty good to me so now what
we're going to do um
is um add these using rag to uh chat gbt
using the open AI API so um we're giving
a system message saying you're a helpful
assistant that helps us with metaflow
essentially um and then we're adding in
our user query and I won't go into all
the Lang chain and open AI stuff we're
doing here um but essentially um we're
using rag now to bring in these
documents um in order to answer this
question and what we see when we convert
it to markdown is to specify condo
dependencies in your metaflow flow you
can use the atondo decorator um The
Decorator allows you to make specific
packages available to metaflow steps and
exactly so we see and it's the example
here it has different um
uh step uh different um dependencies for
each step so we've got numpy here we've
got pandas there which is which is a
nice nice example okay um so we've got
six minutes left and I know where this
is some real 11th Hour stuff and we're
pushing up against it but this was been
a wellward introduction to retrieval
augmented generation the reason we
wanted to do all of that is then show
how you can um put these in production
pipelines using Metal Flow and a
schedule such as Argo so to do
that let
me
actually oh this is
annoying I don't have a slide on that
for some reason okay in our blog post I
meant to add add this slide to there um
we're essentially going to have three
flows which will trigger each other we
have our markdown chunker um which is
the chunking of all the documentation
then the dat pable processor um which
processes everything um and once that's
done we're going to do the vector
indexer which then can be used for for
the for the rag rag stuff right um so
we're going to have all of these
scheduled on Argo to trigger each other
okay
so um
whoa let's
just so in the interest of time I'm not
going to write the command line we can
see when I click
deploy we can see this is scheduled
weekly I clicked deploy Ed and my
terminal went
blank could be a network situation not
sure
about yeah maybe a refresh um the
workflows are already deployed heos
maybe if you just want to like type out
the trigger command it could work
quickly um do in in I do want to show
people how to so yeah so this one will
just be the python Aro workflows create
then exactly so it's we're in
four
flowy
Argo
[Music]
workflows
create and we'll see we've scheduled
this weekly but we're actually going to
trigger it ourselves
today great and we'll see that in the
Aro uh UI in a
second the next one which is the
post-processing workflow we'll see that
um in order to make sure that it's
triggered when the markdown chunker
finishes all we need to do is add the at
trigger on finished decorator there so
that's essentially uh what we're doing
here um so and the point to say is
that's the only difference to doing
things locally um and uh deploying
things so that's in the interest of
making this tool as human Centric as as
possible
um and closing the iterative loop
between prototype and
production so we're deploying this
one and it says look at this beautiful
output this workflow triggers
automatically when the Upstream down
chunker flow succeeds and we're going to
do the same
here python
um 6.
py I go
workflows
[Music]
great great and I'm going to go I love
we got two minutes left I'm going to go
into the Argo
UI and yep we'll see our markdown shun
art data table processor Eddie had
created these some time ago so that's
why they were created at that point um
none of them this has been triggered
some time time ago but not not recently
so we're going to trigger this now so
remember the only thing I need to change
here python 4 section Flow by ago
workflows
trigger and we should see that appear
here in a
second great so we see the markdown
chunker has started well it's about to
start now we've got one minute left um
I'm very happy to answer any questions
and if you need to go please do but what
we should see if you stick around one or
two minutes uh what you should see is
that it will trigger
um the post pressing postprocessing flow
we may not have time to stick around to
see it trigger the pine cone Vector
indexing workflow but all of this this
sandbox is available for you in in in
perpetuity so feel free to play around
with it yourself and come and chat with
us in slack as as well um while this is
running Eddie um ah so let's see if
there are any
questions um oh someone said thank you
for the very interesting Workshop such a
pleasure um Anna um Eddie while this is
oh we can see the start step started
this is good um is there anything you
wanted to
say no just just thanks for everybody
for all the great questions and for the
attention um it was really fun
presenting epod data today and hope to
see see more of you in the the
outerbound slack and keep the
conversation going uh let us know also
if you have requests for more content
like this in the future you and for more
stuff to present like this to our
audience um and as we said come and join
us on slack I'm actually youo Eddie's at
Eddie you can DM us um but any questions
you have specific questions ask them in
public as as well on on slack because a
lot of a lot of other people love to
jump in we've got over 3,000 data
scientists and ml Engineers who love
chatting about this this type of stuff
as well so look we're nearly
there we're one minute over and this
this should end in a in a second and
we'll see the next one triggered and and
start I don't know if it's just on my
side Hugo if it's just my internet but
there's like a just enough of a lag on
the spinning wheel it's just giving me
the like the the spinning wheel of death
feel from the the MacBook kind of
absolutely just the last minute of the
tutorial we're almost there that's
right and okay oh there we go Moment of
Truth yes okay so data table processor
is starting now so we've seen one flow
trigger another which is which is super
cool and actually if you want to
um I think maybe metaflow 2.9 is what we
called it yeah if you want to find out
more about the invent triggering this
was a highly requested feature that a
lot of people are finding value from um
thinking about you know um event
triggering this is a figure we showed
before when data is updated can trigger
a flow similarly um flows of flow so
when you have a training or um flow it
can then trigger an inference flow but
essentially what we've seen um is one
flow trigger another were we to stick
around longer um we' see this trigger
the final final flow to build our rag
production system um oh
whoa great just a
sec H the end step look if anyone wants
to stick around 20 more seconds we
should should be good for
for absolute completeness to
see see this work
um all looks like a whole bunch of
people are still here I'm so happy that
you're you're sticking around I very
much appreciate you for for doing so um
and Eddie uh we've gone to the Argo UI
to have a look at all of this stuff but
correct me if I'm wrong but a lot of
these things will be available in the
metaflow UI at some point as well is
that correct that's correct yeah so I
mean in one sense they're already
available so if you want to go to the
metaflow UI right now we can see it um
yeah eventually metaflow is going to
kind of become a super set of the Argo
UI itself um so this is great what we've
seen is now the computer intensive step
has started but we saw markdown shunka
triggered data table processor which
ended which has now triggered pine cone
vectorizer indexer super exciting which
essentially means we've been able to
build our live production system system
with rag um in order to to do this and I
think that's a wonderful uh note to wrap
up on really appreciate you all joining
I understand we've covered a huge amount
in in 90 minutes I mean this could be a
day long if not a weekl long Workshop
but we wanted to make sure you had
enough things to really go and get
started and jump in and choose what you
want want to use and not um so
appreciate you sticking around a few
minutes longer um and with that um we'll
wrap up and happy to answer any
questions in in in slack or anything
along along those lines as well um so
thank you for joining and thanks once
again to Pi data and Jim for H having us
here